pues el ambiente es de luto muchas
personas familiares o incluso gente de
la comunidad está viniendo aquí algún
elemento y que está detrás mío a dejar
flores hay cruces en la entrada de
la escuela elemental ya con los nombres
de los niños y de los profesores anoche
fue la vigilia miles de ciudadanos de
ubal de una ciudad de cerca de 16.000
personas asistieron en este centro de
convenciones que es más un establo donde
se hace shows de ganadería y de caballos
para estar ahí apoyando a las familias
de las víctimas el ambiente sigue
bastante de luto en la ciudad hay carpas
en varios puntos de la ciudad regalando
comida regalando bebida el calor es
bastante fuerte esto es una ciudad
recordemos apenas a una hora de la
frontera y pues es todavía entonces
mucha gente viene acá se acerca el
colegio hemos hablado de hecho con
algunos de los alumnos y amigos de las
víctimas que están bastante preocupadas
la seguridad de los colegios los padres
incluso están considerando sacarlos de
este colegio llevarlos a escuelas
privadas precisamente por el tema de la
seguridad del ambiente entonces desde
acá desde la escuela elemental es
bastante bastante triste cerca al score
alimentar además hay una funeraria una
funeraria que ya dijo que no iba a
cobrar por los servicios funerales a las
víctimas a las familiares de las
víctimas y ha estado obviamente en este
en este son de ayuda a las familias más
afectadas y cristóbal precisamente en
texas inicia la convención nacional de
la asociación nacional del rifle en el
punto de mira de buena parte de la
sociedad estadounidense que se comenta
en o valdés sobre este encuentro y que
han dicho los políticos sobre la
regulación de las armas en el país
acá en igual de precisamente y en la
vigilia de la noche estaba el senador de
cruz el senador cruz por texas que es el
senador que más te cruz que más ha
recibido apoyo de las empresas de armas
para hacerlo innecesario para que las
armas sigan con las compañías de armas
siga con la probabilidad y la
posibilidad de vender armas en todo el
país hoy de a partir de mañana y este
fin de semana también estará el ex
presidente donald trump allá pues
abogando por ese derecho de las armas
nosotros hemos hablado con varios
ciudadanos aquí anual de precisamente
sobre eso sobre lo que opinan de la
facilidad que es para un joven de 18
años en adelante adquirir un arma para
ellos ese debate que está perdido es eso
no es algo que ellos argumentan y me ha
llamado la atención con los que hemos
hablado aquí que eso no lo consideren
ellos dicen que ya el tema de las armas
se tiene que dar por un hecho que esa
libertad de poseer armas es un hecho
entonces que a partir de ahí tienen que
empezar a trabajar sobre qué van a hacer
para volver los lugares públicos más
seguros es llamativo entonces que ese de
sobre las armas en los ciudadanos de
igual de no es algo que se esté
debatiendo porque ya lo dan por hecho
eso no va a eso no va a cambiar y por
ende tienen quieren trabajar para
mejorar la seguridad en los espacios
públicos y en los colegios